well shiloh see the heavens sorry
welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host definition
in this video we're breaking down one of
the biggest fan theories that you might
have seen surrounding tenet
throughout the movie neil played by
robert pattinson seems to know far more
than you should
and though the reason for this is
revealed at the end it could go far
beyond that
throughout this video we'll be
discussing who we think the character
really is
and the evidence to prove it there will
be heavy spoilers from here on out
so if you haven't seen the film yet then
i suggest you invert yourself
and go back and watch it if you're still
here then thank you for clicking this
now let's get into our breakdown of why
neil is actually cat's son
okay so initially neil just seems like a
contact that was randomly assigned to
the protagonist
to help him with missions however the
character starts to play his hand
more and more throughout the movie and
we realize that he knows far more than
he should
he spouts off dialogue about how time
invasion works
knows about the grandfather paradox and
always seems to be one step ahead of the
game
in the end it's revealed that the
character is actually himself
fully briefed up on exactly what's going
on and we learned that in the future he
was hired by the protagonist
before being sent to protect his younger
self it's a twist that
fatefully leads to the character's death
but i actually think there's a lot more
going on with him
now firstly i just want to shout out
will jd11 who first dropped the theory
on my tenant ending explained video
it wasn't something that i caught first
watch however having gone back to the
film a second time
i think it becomes glaringly obvious
that this is the case
i'm pretty much sat throughout the
second viewing making notes on my phone
which probably ruined the movie for
people behind me but god damn it
this is important work now when we first
meet neil he spouts off two lines of
dialogue
that pretty much cement he's examining
what kind of person that the protagonist
is at that point
when talking to him neil asks would you
take a child hostage
before following this up with what about
a woman
it's something that flies by the first
time however on a second viewing
it becomes clear that he's of course
referring to cat and his son
in order to see whether the protagonist
would be willing to protect them
or if he would risk their lives their
lives are of course paramount to the
storyline
but the fact that he asks about the
child first could be playing his
hand if neil is really max then he would
of course have his own interests at
heart
and he must be sure that the protagonist
is going to do anything he can to
protect him
so that he can return the favor when
he's older he also asks about cat
because if this theory is true and she
is his mother
then he would want to protect her too
after cat is shot at the halfway point
of the movie
neil takes great care of her and pretty
much nurses her back to health
almost going above and beyond what's
expected for a field ops member
neil isn't a medic and the fact that he
spends so much time with her
when he could have easily just took
someone professional along
does hint at what's going on neil also
knows exactly what the protagonist likes
to drink
now this is a point that i think can be
taken as either he is the son or he
isn't
however it does hint towards their
friendship and shows that they've done a
lot of things together socially
rather than just as part of a mission
when the protagonist meets the
scientists at the start of the movie
she makes it clear that they shouldn't
have any chit chat together and that
it's for the best that neither has any
idea who the other is
this is reflected in ives 2 who though a
big player
we actually learned very little about in
fact all of the side characters come
across as people that just pop up and
interact with the protagonist
but they never learn anything about him
or even his true name
neil knowing what he likes to drink
shows that the two have had a
relationship
which goes far beyond the mission and
that they were actually friends
the protagonist is of course very close
to cat at the end of the movie
and he's acting like a guardian angel
for her and a child it is possible after
killing priya and tying up the lastly
send
that he decided to step forward and
become part of their life
if he was close to cat he would of
course become close to her son
and thus neil or rather max
would get to know him on a personal
level this is actually hinted at by neil
at one point in the film
when he says to the protagonist when
this is all over if you still care you
can learn my life's story
again the agents and tenet know very
little things about the other agents
and thus their friendship shows that
they have a relationship outside of the
trappings of the agency
we learn in the film that neil also has
a masters in physics
though we are jumping to conclusions
here this likely means that he took an
interest to it early on in his youth in
order to study it to that degree
this could have been guided by the
protagonist who is watching over the
pair
and likely became part of their life now
one of the biggest hints towards this
i think comes during the car chase we
hear a radio signal
that's pretty much indecipherable the
protagonist says i thought you spoke
estonian
to which neil informs him that though it
is estonian
it is in fact reversed now sato is of
course
estonian himself and it's actually
listed as one of the hardest languages
to learn for english speakers
and it's likely that one could only
grasp it fully if they were brought up
with it
neil is also british which cat is too
but it does go
far beyond that now if you're from
england then you'll know that pretty
much every city has its own dialect and
regional accent
cat meals are very similar which to my
ears at least would only happen
if the pair lived in the same area the
fact that he has an english accent which
is very similar to
cats and also speaks estonian which say
or of course does
brings together the link between the two
and does point out that he was likely
raised by the pair
neil is also very well dressed
this might be a reach but when cat first
meets the protagonist
she remarks on his clothes and can
clearly see through his disguise
she states that he doesn't look like a
billionaire even though he's trying to
come across like one
she has a passion for fashron as does
neil
and if she taught him how to dress it
would explain
why he looks so so bloody fabulous
now when discussing the film as a whole
and pattinson's character
nolan actually dropped a big hint
towards what was going on
in an interview with pink villa the
director stated that neil might actually
have multiple identities
and that neil isn't even his real name
but why would he even bother to give a
fake one
especially if we know how close that he
and the protagonist eventually become
well if he were to give his real name
which would be max if this theory is
correct
then that would of course lead to the
protagonist figuring out things early
and thus he might divert from the
pre-ordained path that the characters
travel on in the film
neil and max also have similar
hairstyles which
bit of a reach a bit of a bit of a reach
there but
one of the biggest clues that the pair
are actually one in the same
pattinson actually dyed his hair for the
role which i can't really see him doing
unless there was a specific reason
max is of course short for maximilian
and the last four letters of maximilian
are leon tenet is of course obsessed
with things reversing
so if we take those letters and reverse
them we then get the name neil
which yeah nice little connection there
neil's journey is of course
just as important as the protagonists
and we learn from priya that the
protagonist is actually one of many
so this name flip might highlight how
integral to everything that he is
sator's square is in fact integral to
the movie as well
and in case you don't know this
real-life latin palindrome actually
contains several things which are linked
to the film
the first line says saito which is of
course the name of the film's villain
the second is areppo which is given as
the name of an art dealer
the third is tennis which are no clues
for guessing that one
the fourth is oprah which is where the
initial siege takes place at
and the final word is rotus which is the
name of the security company
now not only is tenet itself a
palindrome which connects the words
but the entirety of the words laid out
back to front also provides a full
palindrome sentence
in which tenets stands at the middle so
we can take this idea of palindromes
and use them on maximilian and neil to
enforce the idea
that they are one and the same now i
have seen some people say that
in order for this theory to be true then
that would mean that max would have to
grow to a certain age
say around 20 and then invert and go
backwards for an entire 10 years in
order to reach the age which neil is in
the film
this might be the case but it's also
possible that once he hit a certain age
he grew one year going forward reversed
one year
went forward one year and so on and so
forth until he was the age that we see
him in the film
there's also the possibility that when
you invert your body also goes backwards
in time too so you become slightly
younger
so who knows he might have even reached
40 went back
10 years and then we see him at this age
there's a lot of things that could
happen
again this is just a theory and knowing
how nolan is
will likely never get full confirmation
on it but in conclusion
if this is correct then neil grew up
protected by the protagonist
and over this time he learned of how
he'd saved him and his mother's life
when he was younger the pair formed a
friendship together
and neil decided that he would return
the favor and go back in time and save
the protagonist's life during the
mission
he knew things were at stake and that
his sacrifice was of the utmost
importance
and thus embarked on his own journey
through time in which he would become a
crucial cog in the mission
saving not only the protagonist but the
world itself
neil departs the film by saying that
this is the end of a beautiful
friendship for him
but the start of one for the protagonist
and it is possible that after he took
out priya
he went and joined max and cat and this
is what set things off
tenet is getting a lot of criticism at
the moment for for not really having
interesting characters
but if this is true then i think the
theory makes neil far more engaging as a
character
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on whether you agree with me or
not
again there's no right or wrong answers
here and i doubt nolan will ever let us
know himself
but we can always talk about it in the
comments below now if you enjoyed this
video then please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of how time in the movie works
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us center
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been
definition i'll see you next time
take care peace
do